it is June 6 2023 and you're watching
the code report 24 hours ago Apple made
the biggest one more thing reveal since
the iPhone the Apple Vision Pro VR
headset along with its own Vision OS
operating system and a new specialized
R1 chip to power it it's no doubt an
engineering Marvel and this could be a
watershed moment that unlocks a new
paradigm of spatial Computing or on the
other hand it might just be yet another
VR flop that's Dead on Arrival Apple
almost never misses on big announcements
but this product is absolutely insane
and there's a good chance it could fail
which we'll look at in just a minute
first if you missed the worldwide
developer conference keynote let me get
you up to speed by strapping this
magical device to your Dome you can
seamlessly augment the world with your
favorite Excel spreadsheets waste time
watching beautiful 3D 4K movies have
immersive lifelike experiences with your
only fans girlfriend and even record
them to enjoy later in stunning 4K
Clarity while you're doing that it
projects your eyeballs to the front of
the device so you look totally normal to
everybody else and that's great because
if your kids have iPad addictions you'll
be able to have normal family dinners
once again under the hood it's mostly
just a fancy VR headset it has an M2
Chip built into the device along with a
new specially designed R1 chip that can
handle parallel processing for all of
the sensors it has extremely low latency
which is essential for not puking all
over yourself after using it for 10
minutes it's got cameras on the outside
and then eyeball trackers on the inside
what's really crazy is that it uses
something called foveated rendering
which means that it will maximize the
image quality based on where your eyes
are looking at that time it's kind of
like the double slit experiment if you
aren't looking directly at something
those frames are there but they're not
being rendered in addition you control
things with your eyeballs when you look
at icons they'll pop out at you then you
can pinch and swipe with your hand to
select and scroll it can also do voice
commands and even has a virtual keyboard
that's pretty crazy but they missed a
huge opportunity here to give this
product a name of eyeballs but another
feature I really like is that it can
link up to your MacBook allowing you to
use your laptop privately like in a cafe
or on the airplane but you might be
wondering how would you do a video
conference with someone while this thing
is covering your face another weird
thing about this product is that when
you buy it it creates a digital Persona
of your face with AI that allows other
people wearing Apple Vision Pro to see
your real face like in a video
conference or FaceTime now when it comes
to development there's an entirely New
Vision OS operating system to build apps
around all these sensors and I'm sure a
vision OS JavaScript framework is right
around the corner they also released a
new reality composer tool that should
make it easier to build 3D stuff on this
platform in addition they partnered with
unity to provide tooling for vision OS
and unity stock jumped as a result but I
didn't hear any mention of epic games
which is kind of unreal I'm sure it has
nothing to do with that whole massive
lawsuit thing when it comes to games
though there's no physical controller
but I'm sure they'll sell you one in the
near future for 799 dollars either way
Apple Vision Pro is an incredible piece
of Hardware but now I'm done chilling
and gonna turn into a villain because
this product could end up being nothing
more than a dystopian flop first of all
the price is three and a half racks and
you're probably too poor to afford it
just listen to the reaction of the crowd
Apple Vision Pro starts at 34.99 another
problem is that it only has two hours of
battery life and the battery itself
connects to a core that you have to keep
in your pocket or you have to keep the
device plugged in an iPhone or laptop is
still going to be way more convenient
for the vast majority of use cases is
like if I want to take a picture I'm
just going to pull my phone out of my
pocket I'm not going to go strap on my
VR headset and try to capture a special
organic moment with little Billy I
definitely wouldn't want to write code
all day wearing this thing because it
would be drenched with sweat after a few
days of JavaScript coding but another
reason to doubt this product is that
Facebook acquired Oculus and tried to
build a metaverse and even changed its
name to meta and got almost nowhere
after investing tens of billions of
dollars now apple is way more well
positioned to sell a VR product than
meta but at the end of the day I think
it'll be more like an expensive toy than
a revolutionary new Computing Paradigm
and a lot of people think VR technology
is a dystopian scam where the ultimate
goal is to get us to live in pods and
spend our lives working to build
worthless digital assets of course
that's not true but Apple does have a
lot of barriers to break down to get
widespread adoption when it first comes
out in early 2024 you'll likely see a
bunch of insecure dorks wearing these
things around as a status symbol to show
the world that they have a net worth of
over three thousand four hundred ninety
nine dollars another issue is that it's
far more difficult for developers to
create AR VR content compared to your
typical iPhone apps it'll likely get
easier with generative AI technology but
in general there just hasn't been a huge
demand from consumers for AR VR content
with all that said though I do think
there is one big reason Apple Vision Pro
will be successful Confucius once said
the success of any technology hinges on
the degree to which it enables
consumption and apple Vision Pro
definitely checks that box this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one